after the uk's warmest night came its
hottest ever day
previous heat records were smashed
temperatures peaked at 40.3 degrees
celsius in the town of conningsby and
lincolnshire
it is absolutely sweltering here
conningsby is seeing temperatures well
over 40 degrees celsius is not only
being the hottest location in the uk
today but being the hottest british
place on record
for people working it's been
overwhelming
the kitchen has been quite unbearable uh
my business partner robbie's in the
kitchen at the moment and he's not
loving life at all i think it's probably
hitting about 50 degrees in there at the
moment as the sun beat down unrelenting
some schools stayed shut
transport was disrupted
we've already paid for tickets which are
we'll have to clean back and i've just
done online 231 pounds to glasgow and
we're told that's not running from here
either it really surprises me because
i'm from germany and um
we don't
that would never happen the uk
government needs to step up and
start preparing us for climate change
and getting serious about delivering
that zero
across the country everyone and
everything did what they could to keep
cool
more northerly cities better used to
colder weather have adapted
in york gritters that normally deal with
icy roads were out spreading sand onto
melting tarmac
with these record temperatures has come
unprecedented guidance about how people
can stay safe in this extreme heat and
one of those has been telling people to
stay inside if they can and the impact
of that is city centers that today have
looked a little bit like this far
quieter than you'd normally expect for a
sunny day with businesses that simply
decided to stay shut
this gin distillery had to stop
production entirely the first time due
to heat
it is a bit of a blow for all the
traders here everyone must be suffering
today it normally is teeming here and as
you can probably see it's pretty quiet
we'd normally have queues possibly
forming outside the shop not today
today was a day not to enjoy the sun but
to survive it tomorrow's cooler forecast
will bring relief in more ways than one
catherine of totsi sky news